now even though the reason hogwarts
legacy trailer was much shorter than the
one we got at the state of play there is
quite a bit of information in this
trailer particularly about dark magic
let's go ahead and take a deep dive
right now and see how many details we
can find and maybe some possible hints
at how choices will play out in this
game
the more we know about salazar slytherin
and the dark arts the best prepared
we'll be okay the more we know about
salazar slytherin and the dark arts the
better prepared
will be so that is clearly sebastian
talking there and it opens with this
first shot right here that we saw
previously they put this out on twitter
on their social media accounts the
beware the spiders i think this is the
forbidden forest uh some people say
maybe it's not i think it is and i don't
think it would break the cannon even if
it is acromantula in the forest i think
they could easily come up with a way to
get around that
but it could also be a different type of
spider
there are some spiders that we see
in the recent wallpaper that was
released this is going to be on the
deluxe cover of the game this doesn't
look like an acromantula to me so maybe
they're going the route of it being a
completely different type of spider but
even if it is acromantula i think that
would totally work as well if you go
back and look at what aragog actually
said he never said he was the first
spider in the forest and then we have
this line from sebastian about the more
we know about salazar slytherin so
honestly i feel like we've talked a
little bit about merlin
more than we have the actual founders of
hogwarts who could all be a major factor
in this game whenever we got the release
date announcement they showed that
outside shot of hogwarts and you can see
up in the stained glass windows an item
from one of each of the founders iconic
items from the series i might add and
then we have this dark magic trailer
where they're talking all about salazar
slytherin i mean maybe he is going to be
more of a factor than we thought all
right we're going to freeze it right
here in this spot because i think this
is a particularly interesting symbol
right here we can't quite make out what
it is but i wonder if this wasn't
previously blocking this doorway right
here i think the way this trailer is
shot and everything that it's leading up
to clearly this is going into the
dungeon i think that is going to be a
very important area even though it's
optional if you guys didn't catch that
community manager chandler would confirm
that everything in this trailer or i
should say nearly everything is from an
optional quest which may be the craziest
thing about this whole trailer is that
if they're going this in depth on
something that is completely optional
then that bodes very well for the rest
of the game and then this shot right
here is amazing i mean this looks like
something out of dark souls you see the
little candles there floating almost
look like a little spine and i love the
nod to the harry potter movies because
we see almost the exact same design in
the harry potter movies we also have
what appears to be some coffins down
here at the bottom and then we have some
more symbols on the columns right here
and it's hard to really tell who this is
i mean i'm assuming that it's the player
character along with sebastian but as
you're getting ready to see there is
actually another character involved in
this scene as well either of you uses
dark magic i will notify the headmaster
immediately okay so if either of you
uses dark magic i will notify the
headmaster immediately i'm going to bump
it back right here just a little bit
because did you guys catch what he just
said i will notify the head master
basically confirming that it will not be
a head mistress in hogwarts legacy so
you proxy a mole out and i think the
most likely logical choice left is
phineas black now another name that i
have seen some people tossing out
recently is dexter fortescue i think
there's enough evidence to go against it
being fortescue and enough evidence in
favor of black and now that we know it's
not mole based on this line right here i
think it is about 95 sure that it is
going to be phineas black now when it
comes to this gentleman here after the
first time we saw him i think a lot of
people thought it was sebastian's father
now it could in fact still be
sebastian's father but i think this also
confirms that he is a professor at the
school possibly care of magical
creatures maybe this is ernesto jag or
another idea i've seen tossed out as
possibly the caretaker my money is on
care of magical creatures it almost even
looks like the gamekeeper's hut right
there in the background behind him in
this shot here he's clearly someone who
knows of hogwarts he knows of the
wizarding world because he's talking
about notifying the headmaster and it
almost sounds like he knows what is in
this cave because he's specifically
talking about dark magic and as we're
going to see here in a second dark magic
is how they are actually able to
progress in this little area all right
and there we get another shot and i
think this one does not look like
sebastian right here maybe it is i don't
know though it just doesn't look like
him to me then we also have these kind
of uh yellowish glow i think this maybe
is just candles here in the background
and one of the common themes of this
trailer i mean it's dark in general but
it is also actually dark to look at as
well there's a lot of shadowy areas so i
wouldn't be surprised if you guys find
some more details that i miss if you do
please let me know down in the comments
below because i'd love to hear what you
guys have found unforgivable curses are
so named oh dude this shot right here is
one of my favorites i gotta back up we
gotta replay this again because if you
look it almost looks like the snakes are
moving right here look at that
you get kind of that shimmering effect
and this one i mean this has to be
salazar slytherin right maybe it's
merlin he was also a slytherin as well
but considering that they're talking so
much about salazar slytherin in this
trailer i think this is very likely to
be a statue of salazar slytherin and i
just love i did not catch that on the
first a couple of viewings actually how
you i saw the snakes but i didn't see
them having that sort of subtle movement
watch it one more time oh it's kind of
creepy it's almost like it might be a
reflection of maybe some water nearby
and there's a lot going on in these
couple shots here so we had that shot
here of slytherin as they're showing
that they show this strange book that
has a number of different runes we see a
rune here rune most likely here as well
this one's kind of blurred out then over
here and then this other kind of
circular one right here and then a mark
that a lot of people have been talking
about because it looks so close to the
mark of the deathly hallows now it's not
because it doesn't have the wand so i
don't think it's the deathly hallows i
have read some comments from other
people saying that traditionally a
triangle with a circle in the middle is
somehow related to alchemy so maybe
nicholas flamel maybe something to do
with a sorcerer's stone or philosopher's
stone depending on where you're at and
as much as i'd like to say oh man it's
clearly the mark of the deathly hallows
i just can't because it is definitely
missing the wand through the middle
a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable
okay a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable now sebastian
actually bringing up an interesting
point right there fans of the series
will know that harry used a couple of
the unforgivable curses on more than one
occasion so it certainly raises an
interesting moral question and i think
this game is going to put us in several
of those scenarios where we have to
choose we have to react and figure out
if we think it is worth using an
unforgivable curse or not now when it
comes to the actual scenes that we just
saw we get a great shot here of yet
another just kind of dark
moody atmospheric i mean you've got the
fog going on you have these massive
bones which i mean this has to be from
the hyperidian black dragon right does
this mean that at some point in the game
we are going to kill or take down this
dragon maybe we witness poachers taking
down the dragon how many of those
hyperidian black dragons are actually
out there and the reason i think it's
that one is because if you look at this
little uh what is it i mean you guys
should call it a horn here kind of that
sticks out the side of the mouth side of
the head then we have the thestrals over
here also another thestral flying here
in kind of the top left corner and then
we have some birds flying around as well
oh and don't forget the little rat right
there hey uh rats confirmed as pets for
hogwarts legacy i don't know but they're
clearly in the game and then we get
another shot right here with more of the
beware spider sign so you know what i am
thinking that the gamekeeper i think it
is ernesto jag the gentleman that we
hear talking in this trailer maybe
that's not his name whatever but i do
think he is the game keeper and i think
he is the one who put up these signs
again because of what he was saying in
that opening part of the trailer i think
he knows what is back there and as we're
going to see here toward the end of the
trailer he ends up finding and tracking
down the students as well so i clearly
think he knows his way around this area
and it wouldn't surprise me at all if he
is the one who in fact put up these
signs and then this is one of just like
the creepiest shots of the entire
trailer we get this scene with all these
spiders and then we get someone clearly
this appears to be a human who has been
wrapped up in
the webbing of these spiders and we can
hear them screaming muffled but we could
definitely hear them and then we just
get kind of this zoom out shot from
overhead
oh and then i love the transition here
it goes from that shot to then this shot
of it we're sort of deep in a cavern and
looks like the camera is pulling down in
that one now here in this next scene we
continue to move our way i think through
this dungeon that they set up at the
beginning of the trailer i don't know if
this is salazar slytherin's tomb i don't
know if it's another area that he built
similar to the chamber of secrets but
this clearly has a heavy heavy influence
of salazar slytherin look along the wall
you almost certainly have seen the
snakes there we've got all the spider
webs as well and then in this next scene
get ready for it because we're going to
see a third character a lot of people
have been talking who is this third
character we have sebastian here in the
front we have our player character here
and then back here i am watching this at
the 4k version because on the initial
viewing i totally missed this this area
of my screen was just too dark it was
too blacked out i could not even see
that anyone was there so there are lots
of questions about this individual is it
just some sort of random side character
who happens to be going with us is that
another companion it clearly looks to be
a slytherin given their robes maybe it's
just a friend of sebastian's we don't
know but then sebastian here at the
front comes to an area where crucio is
written across the floor thus confirming
the second unforgivable curse for
hogwarts legacy which i think basically
confirms all three i mean come on you're
not gonna have two and not do the third
right so avada kedavra crucio 100
confirmed and i'm gonna go ahead and say
i think it's highly likely that imperio
is in as well personally i think imperio
is the one that has the most gameplay
scenarios the most gameplay utility
going for it but here they're going to
show off a use case for crucio and in
this case it involves getting through
this area so listen to what sebastian
says here to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you
i'm ready
so he says i can teach you crucio or i
can cast it on you then we get that
interesting pan back of the camera where
it sort of splits the screen in two and
i think they stopped just short of
showing us something but what they're
suggesting there is almost certainly a
moment of choice we are going to have to
decide as the player do we have
sebastian cast crucio on us or do we
choose to take part in the dark magic
and cast crucio on him now what's
interesting about this is that it looks
like you will be able to progress this
quest whether you want to play as good
or evil and then again is it even really
considered evil if sebastian is
willingly allowing you to cast it on him
harry potter fans will remember to cast
crucio you have to mean it in fact harry
tries to cast it on bellatrix and it
just does not work so i wonder how
they're going to get around that here
because it's not something that you can
just like oh i want to cast it because
we need to get by this door now in all
the craziness that happened after the
gamescom trailer we also learned that
hogwarts legacy will not feature a
morality system they updated the
official faq and said this but
reconfirmed that we will have choices to
make in the game that will determine the
witch or wizard we want to be and we
clearly see one of those choices here
and so now my next big question is what
are the consequences you know does it
matter if we choose to cast crucio or
have it cast upon us in this scenario is
there any difference at all will there
be some sort of in-game representation
of our wizard or witch changing as they
go down the dark path will the world
around us change will characters react
to us in a different way will we have
different endings i think that is the
biggest one that people want to know
about and i was a little bit worried
when they said that no morality system
because i'm kind of thinking okay if
there's no morality system then how does
it track i mean does it even matter at
all as long as they have some sort of
repercussion some sort of impact of the
choices you make and some sort of
difference then i think it will still be
meaningful even if there isn't some sort
of system that's statistically tracking
how dark versus how light you are
you've made your choice
and then we hear a different voice a
voice that sounds to be a female voice a
pained female voice and it seems to be
directed at sebastian saying you've made
your choice let's listen to it one more
time here
you've made your choice
i have no idea who that could be maybe
it's the lady that we saw in the other
trailer with sebastian maybe it's
someone that we haven't met yet at all
maybe it's sebastian's mother then we
get another shot of inferi they have
focused a lot on inferior in all the
trailers we've seen them in every single
trailer so far and they're also going to
appear in the deluxe edition cover art
along with dementors now dementors
appear in the cover art as well but
what's interesting is they have not been
focused on nearly as heavily in the
trailers in fact we've only seen them in
that first big reveal trailer and that's
it and honestly i was beginning to
wonder because when we didn't see them
at all and nobody had really mentioned
them i was kind of starting thinking
okay maybe they decided not to include
dementors in the game but the fact that
they're including them on the box art
for the deluxe edition i mean i think
they're in which also if you have
dementors does that not confirm expecto
patronum i mean we have to have a way to
combat dementors and a patronus is the
only way to do that and then we get a
nice look at some more combat in this
game combat against the inferior and
back to the inferior for a second here's
the thing i want to know about them who
created them that's right who created
them guys because fans of the series
will know that and fury don't just
appear on their own every single time
there is an inferior there is a dark
wizard at the center of it so a dark
wizard has to cast a terrible curse to
even make this a possibility to even
make this happen and it seems like there
are plenty of inferior in this game so
who is behind all this i mean do they
give us a hint in the trailer right here
because watch what happens as soon as we
go from this scene we go from this
to this wizard right here a mask wizard
some people are saying
this is rookwood i don't know if it's
rookwood i mean it certainly fits we've
got the hat here we've got the mass
we've got him casting this curse against
our main character our main character
blocking it with protego maybe it is
rookwood
and there's a look at protego right
there we also get the sound effect for
protego did you guys catch that i think
protego is gonna be a super fun spell to
use and obviously a critical critical
part of gameplay in hogwarts legacy and
then do i see blood right here flying up
in the air after this spell rebounds
back and hits the person who was casting
it against us then we get another shot
of sebastian because clearly
something goes awry when we are down in
this dungeon with sebastian and they are
having to fight off a lot of inferior
and who knows what else down there now
what's interesting about that dark
wizard is that could very well be from a
different scene we're not sure
so we get the shot of sebastian fighting
we get the shot of the inferior burning
and then this scene
right here when i was talking about this
scene with my chat a lot of people were
saying this is the slytherin common room
now it's a possibility we get another
glimpse at that mysterious character
over here on the right i think it's the
same person anyway i do not think it's
sebastian but the reason i don't think
it's a slytherin common room is because
we have these spider webs over here i
mean wouldn't they make sure to clean
that up or do they just think it goes
with the slytherin vibe i don't know i
mean we know that the slytherin common
room is in the dungeons but watch the
way this scene progresses i do not think
it's a slytherin common room because
watch right after this
the doors open and then it immediately
goes into this shot right here up just
this incredibly creepy step
of bones and then it has the character
walk through this area into this area
right here so i think they are still in
this kind of dungeon-like area and this
shot right here is incredible and also
horrifying at the same time i mean look
at all the spider webs now we went from
a few spider webs to spider webs
everywhere we can see captured prey
hanging from the ceiling i don't even
want to know what that is are those more
in fury are those humans that have been
captured along the way is it something
else entirely we have no idea but this
shot right here just has so many details
in i mean you've got the reflections on
the water you've got the flames you've
got the shadows just so moody so
atmospheric i love it and you guys
already know i mean there's a giant
spider at the end of this there has to
be a giant spider boss or a horde of
spiders for us to take on as we're
trying to escape this area we get a
glimpse at some more runes on the column
here to the right
now this scene right here is absolutely
fascinating to me because if you watch
it i'm going to play it a couple of
times here it clearly seems like this
troll
is targeting the
inferior now that first swipe you may
just think oh the inferior was in the
way maybe the inferior was standing in
front of the player i could get that but
then if you watch when he actually goes
to swing down i mean he is trying to
punish this inferior that is attacking
so it's that second blow that big swing
downward that leads me to believe there
is something else
going on here so i don't know if this
troll is working on our side or maybe
just maybe
we have cast the imperious curse
on this troll to get him to fight for us
i think that would be an insane moment
or or or i just thought of this one as i
was recording maybe the dark wizard who
set these in fury loose is also one of
the dark wizards who is imprisoning all
of these magical creatures and this
troll has just had enough the straw is
like that's it i'm done i'm breaking out
of here and then maybe we're just kind
of a bystander but i love the variety of
the magical creatures this is a
completely different type of troll than
we have seen in the other
of you trailer
we get another shot with this professor
maybe gamekeeper we're not really sure
but he has clearly made his way into the
dungeon where sebastian and our player
character are at the time and he is not
happy what have the two of you done he
knows something is wrong we get the cut
to sebastian right here who looks just
absolutely terrified he knows they've
messed up and now it seems that the
professor is going to have to help us
get out of this situation but think
about all the story repercussions from
this you guys maybe because if this is
the set way that it has to happen like
maybe this guy has to find us every
single time then he's already said he's
going to notify the headmaster so does
this mean that sebastian gets expelled
from the school does this mean that
we'll face consequences if we were the
one that used crucio so this goes back
to what we were talking about is will
there be consequences so what if we
think we're making the good choice and
we do not want to cast crucio so we say
to sebastian hey you cast it on us but
then he's already had all the run-ins
with the headmaster at hogwarts and so
they're just gonna be like no dude
you're out of here what if we actually
get him expelled but if we cast crucio
what if he somehow gets to stay and then
i don't know we get detention or
something now these curses were made
unforgivable all the way back in 1717
well before hogwarts legacy it's a
little bit unclear what exactly the
punishments were at the time but we know
by harry potter's day i mean if you cast
these on another human being that is
supposed to be an azkaban life sentence
in fact the only way out of this was if
the caster did so under the influence of
the imperius curse which was something
that was commonly argued after the first
wizarding war for people to try and get
out of it and we do get a very nice shot
of hogwarts here in the background we
get a great look at the thestral which
unfortunately is locked behind the
deluxe edition that is the only way to
get the thestral mount guys so if you
want to fly at all on astral that is not
something that you'll be able to unlock
in the game any other way and then dude
this dark arts pack i'm not trying to
sound like a fanboy here but i actually
think it looks really slick i love the
look of this dark arts attire and now
even though this trailer focused heavily
on the dark side and the dark magic and
hogwarts legacy it did not even begin to
scratch the surface of all the
possibilities and if you are interested
in what that may look like then you have
to check out the video on the right side
of your screen now because i recently
did a deep dive video on dark magic in
harry potter and how it may be used in
hogwarts legacy as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon